metro police say they've arrested the
man responsible for two violent crimes
that happened last week a murder
and a separate shooting police say both
crimes happened in the area of decatur
and penwood
just south of sahara orcomanna reports
police say a homeless man was shot and
killed in this area last monday
and then just days later another man was
shot but he survived
now police say that they found the
person responsible
21 year old nola green was arrested in
connection to both crimes police have
surveillance video from july 13
showing the homeless man identified as
48-year-old brent lloyd
being shot to death and the shooter is
said to be green a couple days later a
man was shot in the chest while walking
his dog police say both shootings seemed
similar and were unprovoked
a tip led police to green and they found
disturbing videos on green's cell phone
showing both shootings including the
homeless man's murder
police calling it a thrill killing we
are confident in saying
today that we believe we have taken a
very
dangerous person off of the streets
and we believe that he would have
committed the crime of murder again
had it not been for the actions of this
agency
police are also continuing to look at
more evidence to figure out if green is
connected
to any other violent crimes in the area
green faces murder
and attempted murder charges he's being
held without bail
and is due in court wednesday reporting
in las vegas orca mana 8 news now